uh i have to tell you guys this story um
i do not command respect
i do not command respect at the airport
at least at the airport on a flight i
mean in first class right i think it's a
little bit different with delta because
we have status yeah yeah so i think the
flight attendants they know you they
know they know what they're talking
about they got the list they know your
boys [ __ ] diamonds yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but we weren't on delta we
were an american um
you're a stranger you're a refugee yeah
unbelievably
[Laughter]
movies is kind of funny yeah but delta
got good movies too i always find
something to watch i never watch zelda
movies and you lying what are you doing
the whole sleep yeah
we on this [ __ ] american flight we're
coming back right now i'm thinking i'm
gonna get some respect you're mr america
i'm mr america you tried to save america
son i did try to save america that's a
great ass point they should know this
yeah male stewardess oh
oh
talk about not respecting somebody male
stewardess straight
if you gay bet if you straight come on
get a real job
three days a week well you don't care
about your family you're not a family
man if you're gay travel the world suck
dicks get [ __ ] yeah this is the best
job if you're a gay dude are you kidding
me yeah come on now
come on you want to do vacation vacation
cheap just pay your taxes yeah you can
travel anywhere in the world it's the
perfect job if you're a man if you're a
bachelor gay or straight bachelor do it
it's a [ __ ] 50 year old man you saw
the dude yeah 50 year old man bye coming
by maybe he was buying maybe he's bi
maybe he's bi but he comes over he goes
uh uh ask him for the sandwich options
he goes uh we have a oh i heard this
always have a
he goes uh i go well what do you options
because uh he goes we have a turkey
sandwich and a vegetarian sandwich and i
go hmm i go
what's in the veggie sandwich
right he goes
guy looks at me and goes uh
not meat
and then you double down i was so upset
i looked i said no [ __ ]
out loud
or like maybe louder than i just said
right now yeah i was upset i forgot the
texture about this thing this is like
the ford [ __ ] stewardess that
actually did some [ __ ] disrespectful to
me so i had enough it's just knee-jerk
reaction he goes uh not meat i go no
[ __ ]
and i almost kept doubling down what
else does not have [ __ ] door handles
what else is not in the sandwich [ __ ]
he's gonna tell me it's not a [ __ ]
sandwich maybe i'm allergic to one
and of the
[ __ ]
blowing up on this flight yeah now tell
him what you actually said i said i'll
take the vegetarian
no but did you double down i think he
said something like you were like oh but
what's in it he's like
the label doesn't list the vegetables
i didn't get paperwork paperwork yeah
yeah i'm like what paperwork he's an
illegal immigrant
paperwork like oh he's about to blow up
crazy with paperwork because what do you
mean paperwork they're not going to tell
you which veggies what if i'm allergic
we're not allergic to cucumbers and i
have allergic reactions sorry the
sandwich doesn't come with carfax andrew
it still come with carfax you got
nothing to do i'm tired of just got
lemons asking acting like they got the
hardest job
why do they act like they got the
hardest job you are you a sky waitress
and there's like four items it's just
you that's one part of your job should
be knowing what the [ __ ] you're feeding
me
know what you're feeding me sir
no it's in the veggie it's limited three
veggies
that the students hit him with a you
done and he's like i'll take the turkey
he didn't say you died
yeah i knew it was in the turkey turkey
that was the right way to go the veggie
was some weird it was like orange paste
it was like just mush you can't it was
just [ __ ] mush with a couple of
peppers inside it was horrible how the
[ __ ] harv
did he not know what was in that
sandwich i couldn't i couldn't tell you
what was it this orange mush
yeah with a couple peppers i wish i
ordered it and then chucked it in his
[ __ ] head i wish i said hey can you
come here can i have a diet coke and
there's threw it right in his [ __ ]
head
what a piece of [ __ ] that guy would not
meet
can you believe he said that
at his job
this is his job how many seats are in
first class on this place
literally six on each side there's 12
seats yeah there's 12 people he got to
be nice to
talk about the [ __ ] that was just
bossing everybody around like she worked
on that [ __ ]
you didn't hear no the lady on the left
i was on my dondo oh
the lady on the left side she's like oh
you know i just i have over a million
miles and she's just bossing the
stewardess around he's like oh yeah
there's one open seat here like nah
he'll move over like i'm like who is
this [ __ ] but i like her style so he
took that [ __ ] out on me he probably did
so
he was doing it can i tell you where he
gave him an opening when he said what
kind of sandwich you want and you go hmm
something about that
i was like this wild annoying yo [ __ ]
this guy
what do you want me to say that's some
[ __ ] ass options for first class
that i played full hour upgraded that's
what andrew say on the ground i don't
know what happens to you at 30 thousand
people yeah i don't know what happens
damn i get bitched up
what happened i walked in my seat was
supposed to be 3a and i walk in and they
somebody's sitting there he's like oh
yeah we moved you because we wanted to
sit together as a couple
like didn't even actually and i just
really just i said i'll i'm
i don't care if it's the same seat maybe
i want to look out the left side yeah
maybe the sun is hitting the left side
yeah yeah they suck they sandwich you
dog yeah yo what's in the seat not you
yeah [ __ ] allison in the back i can't
believe i say nothing i was all right
okay i'm not supposed to be here that's
the imposter syndrome [ __ ] we used to go
oh okay
they'll know that i'm not supposed to be
here [ __ ] that we paid for the tickets
i want my turkey sandwich in my veggie
sandwich
piece of [ __ ] hey tell me what's in the
[ __ ] sandwich i want to know the
bread i want to know the mayo i want to
know all that this is like the end of
seven dude like what's in the sandwich
what's in the box
bro
it's easier for them because it's all
pre-packaged [ __ ] but it's one of like
son it's just one nice music
they don't know what is turkey you ran
out of turkey sandwiches but it got to
me that's why i have to get the veggie
can i be honest with you oh you got
double goods
on the way there when we when we look at
us just the champagne problems but on
the way there there's 12 people
12 of both
it's a six dollar sandwich we paid
fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred it's crazy it gets so
expensive
it's crazy so i'm on the way down there
this drives me [ __ ] nuts it's two
options for breakfast on the way there
that they had would you like the eggs or
were you like a [ __ ]
belgium waffle oh that sounds fire no no
no no no no ten percent body fat tour
dog we trying to keep it cute you're
ready right we have dessert and
breakfast you'll have two breakfasts you
got dessert and breakfast
i'm in the third row maybe sakura i'm
close she'll definitely get breakfast
yeah you'll even get eggs
comes up to me
uh uh would you like belgian waffle i go
what's up with the eggs so we don't have
any eggs left you didn't prepare for
your job today eggs come in a dozen
times how do you only have half a dozen
no
you got 12 eggs at every garden it's
unfucking believable shut up what
happened
you didn't prepare for your job you
forgot your name tag yeah you your job
is to make sure everybody in this
section gets some [ __ ] eggs if they
want
that is very reasonable is that not
reasonable american airlines trash
you're the big winner in this mark no i
got cucked yesterday too oh jesus dog i
was in this restaurant and i was like
that's ground [ __ ] yeah i know i got
cooked on the ground
he just goes yo you want uh oysters we
got the best oysters in everywhere in
the whole new york and i was like yeah
let me get some oysters and he gave us
the menu we filled it out wrote the
circles like jonathan the whole show
did the whole thing looked at the price
we're like looking at the checking
account make sure we got it good and
then all of a sudden he comes over and
goes
yo oysters just ended 10 minutes ago i'm
so sorry i leave on that [ __ ] i was like
he was like i should have told you
before my bad i'll leave spit in his
face and leave i just saw you guys like
i'll take the hummus as [ __ ] oh my gosh
with your girls i know it's our
anniversary bro yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's worse that's worse
we just didn't get a sandwich that's
worse what did they do to make up for
their blunder
uh they said uh nothing they said
nothing they didn't offer you something
around or something like that no no no
no no leave man
i know that you couldn't because this is
it was the anniversary that's where they
went that's how you celebrate let's
leave this [ __ ] high and dry
yeah did you go to that restaurant
specifically for a particular reason no
this is like an after spot i don't know
how i got that i'll just do it
i impressed myself
access specifically at particular yeah
[ __ ] with your boy
[ __ ] spear over here also we figured
out's problem okay so he's got something
called speech jammer in his head what is
that yeah a speech jammer you ever heard
of this no speech jammer's a weapon that
they use japanese guy invented it
basically you hold the speaker as
someone it's like a gun thing like a
megaphone and it takes in your voice and
then spits it back to you on a one
second delay and then it gets in your
brain and then you can't talk
yeah why is that torture it's a real
thing it stops you from speaking let's
say you're out of protest and you're
like trying to speak they could point
the gun to you and then stop you from
speaking shut down the whole protest and
that's what al has inside his actual
brain boom
you think you could beat the speech
jammer yeah oh you could beat it yeah
well i got one let's go son
i think you got set up
i'm not sure but i think you got set up
i'm ready to go let's go it's like it
works oh this is gonna be good all right
it's gonna be somebody can feel your
pain finally yeah
can you pull up something for him to
read real quick okay okay you get to
read it off the tv this is so easy what
you want to read or what you want to
read whatever y'all want
all right little baby lyrics yeah a
little bit yeah get up a little bit
that's fine i got that all right
oh yeah he has to have the headphones on
all right get the lyrics out before you
start don't start till you get the
lyrics
chocolatey
chocolatey done they're lie all right
this is a freestyle little baby all
right let's go
oh sorry sorry mayor come here
all right
some some of these words shouldn't be
saying
shout out to my labeler that's me i'm in
this [ __ ] with the tb i'm in this [ __ ]
with four trey i just poured up me an
eight real n word all in my face 500
racks in my safe 500 racks of the plug
what you know about showing love what
you know about pulling up the bentley
trucks make these [ __ ] fall in love
all of my n-words on go none of my
anwar's no hoe all of my animals want
smoke all of my adwords together we came
for the bottom we used to wear each
other clothes none my hand not
through so that available tried it at
the beginning and he was like
it's easy all right all right hold on
let's let's go i'll be honest i have a
lot of experience just talking over
people and through them so this is not
this is absolutely nothing to me
all right what we got
all right go hit it we ain't gonna fall
out boat hoes me and said got them lows
we let them go for the low i got my hood
in control i got my left wrist on froze
i got my right wrist on froze i got my
necklace on frost both my ears are
frozen i be getting faded i'm sipping on
maple maple if she won't [ __ ] i won't
make a maker
so you're not [ __ ] i [ __ ] little baby
yo what absolute [ __ ] are you kidding
me
but they're already the quietest people
so when they muster up the courage to
talk at all
so you throw any little you know
discrepancy mm-hmm oh yeah you can't
forget it probably can't even interrupt
out there yeah